hey John hey Greg we're the real region
real region we are life speaking of life
Ryan Reynolds and Jake Gyllenhaal a new
movie called life
all right joined right I'm so ready hi
this I love Jake Gyllenhaal Jake
Gyllenhaal's great I love Reynolds and
there's someone else in this or figure
out let's find out no man can fully
grasp how far and how fast him come
the Celia there is no strife no
prejudice no national context get up you
don't have with the hospital tours all
its non West deserves the best of all
bad time and it's opportunity for
peaceful corporation they never come
again oh no
oh my god the missions primary code has
been achieved looking at on a single
sound logical ah it resulted on the
tongue but I think it's time we're
looking at the first proof of life
beyond Earth
finally daddy it's gonna be a big
custody battle over this one hi there
with the jokes
we set sail we have dog button
and greatest adventure on which man has
ever embarked Oh will continue to be a
pioneer in the new frontier of space
damn very alien reminiscent I hope the
twist is that guy was just joking just
kidding guys it's not grabbing me I
would like a really extended versions I
knew them in every forest no that isn't
a Sheldon well in the back of his head
lace is dig and he had that like that
gritty lot British voice you know so
first thing I'm just used to Hollywood
only acknowledging you just so looks
like the only black actor so like what
every time someone's like let's make a
character black people ages oh man I'm
like there are other black actors that
exist you're done John you're done John
oh no I mean this is totally alien yeah
a dread on a stage there I am you my
form that starts to like destroy
everyone the shiver the lighting this is
gonna be a new awaken exactly alien and
it's the writers of Deadpool is it yeah
Rhett Reese Paul Wernick my way the guys
did Zombieland GI Joe retaliation it's
gonna be a comedy hey man maybe they're
breaking out I'm excited for them to
break my Reynolds had a funny line in
there who's directing this it is daniel
espinosa director of safe house with
ryan reynolds just a bunch of people who
worked with ryan rounds were like let's
get right wouldn't reach me about this
is seeing Jake Gyllenhaal and Ryan
Reynolds act together what's surprising
is you don't really see much Jake
Gyllenhaal in this trailer something
tells me he's probably gonna die early
he's like that guy where it says in the
credits and Jake Gyllenhaal and Jorge
like I thought let's everyone in the
cast we're gonna use his name but don't
get too attached yeah yeah I don't know
how to feel about this trailer cuz like
I had the concept is cool until you only
familiar until you go you have seen this
many times I'm
interested in this mostly because like
the cast looks good yeah ugly and space
is always intriguing yeah you like I'm
always interested in a space thriller
but nothing about this trailer is unique
enough to me to be like I gotta see this
movie
yeah wife is the one for me because I
mean I mean space thrillers are a very
intense and very exciting yes space is
[ __ ] scary however I mean in this
trailer I think like right outside of
her we see a clip where they're really
close yeah or that might just be a
shower they're leaving Earth yeah I
don't know with it know all this shit's
breaking off and stuff and if that's
Earth right there okay has to be
hopefully unless it's an alien less it's
another planet
yeah it looks kind of earth as they went
through some type of wormhole and
everything's different but I don't think
I'll go that far I'm pretty sure hey
never know man the third X of these
movies can get crazy I don't know I feel
like there's a lot of great space movies
out there and this seems to be borrowing
from a lot of different space movies III
don't quite see what the signature
unique touches yeah
like sunshine was great gravity was had
its own unique hook to it it dissipate a
lot of people love it it seems to be one
of those movies to that because a lot
people love I love people's gonna hate
it now but I think gravity had a very
unique hook to it there's nothing really
here that seems to have a very strong
unique hook
I mean Prometheus did the whole thing of
this is the first life ever it is you
know this is what's responsible for
humanity's with me now it's just killing
human beings do you know I'd like this
to be more than just some type of
mystery horror space thriller I would
like it if they could be a little bit
more ambitious and try to give some
actual like crazy sci-fi answers to
what's going on yeah cuz I something
tells me they're gonna go down the
Prometheus or the first alien rare you
don't really get answers on what's going
on it's just about them surviving then
Ryan Reynolds has a flamethrower oh boy
I can't tell if it feels small or if it
just feels claustrophobic because one of
those could be really good it's like
everything is really tight in this what
it looks like a small space what it
looks to me that might be a unique touch
is instead of them all band
being together to try to survive it
looks like a lot of them are going to
keep turning on each other to try to
survive because the space is so small I
feel like they're probably gonna be like
I want this room I'm containing in this
room this is mine you stay out so sure
that last shot with Jake Gyllenhaal Ryan
Reynolds looking at each other lovers
well yeah and and you know I guess I am
a bit intrigued by you know like what is
the nature of the alien what is it doing
to that to the scientist who's you know
being sucked into the containment
chamber you know is it gonna be like the
thing where like infects you and that's
like a communicable thing or is it gonna
be you know more like a monster slasher
thing it would be cool if they became
like a monster kind of thing like I
would I wouldn't mind seeing a movie
where they're all turning on each other
that would be kind of cool I mean I
might not make it fully make sense with
the same target people involved yeah
because this is a very contained
environment and it looks like they're
fighting to have their own little
containment to keep safe you're freaking
out yeah like maybe did someone get
infected and or like is it possible for
them to get affected by the life-force
or like no you got to stay away from me
now and stuff they got such a great
ensemble here of actors and I feel like
though they'll do their best to take
advantage of that I'd be really shocked
if they didn't there are movies that do
that better they don't I get an alright
vibe off this trail and I don't know why
like I feel like it best this movie
might be like all right I don't know
what's missing from this for maybe yeah
looks like a lot of snow icing form it
is there's no real unique touch yeah it
just doesn't have a flavor that that
seems all its own even though like you
know all movies borrow from each other I
get it at the same time this doesn't
have enough of a distinct thing it has a
bunch of almost distinct things to me
like how cool I like you know this
collection of people and oh cool I like
your spaceship kind of looks cool and oh
that's a neat alien life-form but
nothing is so distinct oh my god of
Cedars I want to see like how does the
life-form affect them yeah I like this
culture there's a life-form get into
them and like cause them to behave weird
is it like the thing where it takes over
though you know because it was the thing
to like like it can mirror the body well
yeah I mean the thing can sort of take
on the shape of any two
shifting kind of creature yeah yeah well
yeah I would like to see what this
creature does what this life creature is
but because so far the most intriguing
parts of the trailer to me was the very
last moment when Jake Gyllenhaal and
rutan Ryan Reynolds are like on opposite
side Jake Gyllenhaal's ally Ryan
Reynolds in maybe Jake Gyllenhaal's
sacrificing himself yeah or maybe he's
like why are you blowing off a
flamethrower inside of a space station
ah bad idea
yeah that's true cuz this is a game song
this doesn't seem like it's like in the
so far distant future like the first
alien yeah I was a giant space I was
sleeping for hundreds of years
don't worry about oxygen levels I love
this shot of them the look and H are
going we're to the best looking men in
Hollywood right now let's kiss we are to
the most successful Hollywood actors
right other side of this circular glass
look at us staring at each other we
don't even exchange dialogue people just
want us to notice each other what if
they both can't see each other and they
can only see each other like they're on
vacation they were never there on the
same day they're both looking at their
reflections in the gun we are the
best-looking astronauts another we get a
really attractive astronauts in
Hollywood girl Yuki Sanada who I
remember from Wolverine rush hour 3 Last
Samurai sunshine sunshine and um you
know Rebecca Ferguson who was in the
great science fiction action movie
Mission Impossible rogue nation and
she's going to be an mi6 an
international space crew discovers life
oh so they go to Mars yeah oh we should
read this little plot description before
we think it's talking international
space crew discovers life on Mars and
they're right outside of Earth and then
[ __ ] starts to go wrong yeah scary
another movie where they find some bad
force on bar
we need to stop trying to go to Mars
people I don't think we learn anything
from going to mother parties like the
worst place to go to according to every
film it's the idea I get from
eyewitnesses don't try it just don't
just read and Mars that you can't trust
it it him the Martian even takes place
on Mars and it just seems like a very
boring planet let's just cuz the people
inside didn't come out you know there's
like a door underneath the suit Marvin
the Martian Neverland I'm tired does
that happen or John Carter's ghost of
Mars John Carter's good John Carter from
Mars John Carpenter's goes to Mars John
Carter why did they remove of Mars from
the title of that cuz like cuz John Karr
is a very unique name and it's very
intriguing for a sci-fi action spectacle
I'm too tired that I just thought of the
guy went to high school I feel like Jake
Gyllenhaal especially is very particular
about the films he does even if the film
itself doesn't get the strongest
feedback like southpaw for example is
the film I got like a decent feedback
like a lot of people thought it was
great a lot he was anything it was just
okay a lot of people thought was
conventional but the one thing no one
can dispute is that Jake Gyllenhaal
[ __ ] rocks it in that film yeah I
mean he's really proven himself in the
last several years like he's turned
around to now when I hear Jake John
hauls in a movie I am interested and
like but then every once in a while he
does like a random supporting role like
Everest tennis like what's he doing it
and then he has like some films that
come out that aren't greatest but
usually for these like bigger kind of
films I imagine that Jake Gyllenhaal
like he's a little bit more particular
about this and the director and the
writers have worked at Ryan Reynolds
before and looks like Ryan Rollins will
be the main lead in this there's good
track records with a lot of these people
involved so I'm hoping that it ends up a
good film but right now I think it needs
a better trailer yeah I hope it can all
coalesce that's the thing it's like I
like a lot of the stuff that's here and
I don't know how it's gonna come
together to form a complete whole right
now cuz I don't know how that ensembles
gonna play you know it's like am I gonna
be distracted that it's Ryan Reynolds
and all these other people and maybe not
but I don't know
like this yeah this trailer doesn't kind
of give me enough to take place in the
gravity universe where at one point they
see just a dribble of flipping through
space and they catch her on their big
robot re rejects if you need the channel
subscribe to doing good accepted say
this fast to us a social media manager
at facebook.com slash blue Mouse at
facebook.com slash the real Regis use
that reason to Gerry on Instagram and
Twitter have a good night